our top story this hour this is the
final weekend before the midterm
elections where control of Congress
hangs in the balance some notable names
are hitting the campaign Trail to help
give their Canada Choice the final push
that's not all from former NFL stars to
Media personalities there is also a lot
of star power on the ballot as CBS
news's Caitlin Huey Burns reports this
isn't the first time popularity and
politics intersect
in the final stretch of the campaign
season candidates typically deploy
celebrities to help turn out the vote
you may be asking what is lin-manuel
Miranda doing here but this cycle it's
the year of the celebrity candidate
former football star Herschel Walker is
challenging Democratic senator Rafael
Warnock in Georgia and Dr Mehmet Oz we
have never done before is running for an
open senate seat in Pennsylvania and
together we're going to make this happen
God bless you all for being here the
spotlight is on support for these two
celebrities turned candidates will
determine which party controls the U.S
Senate celebrities are no strangers to
politics look no further than the last
White House occupant who proved
celebrity Ken Trump experience they love
me but the road was paved long before
him for offices big there have been
times in this office
when I wondered how you could do the job
if you hadn't been an actor and small
the campaigning is very difficult I must
say it's much more difficult than making
a movie Clint Eastwood served as Mayor
of Carmel California campaigning on
fighting bureaucracy and the city's ban
on ice cream cones when it comes to
celebrities turned politicians there
have been comedians wrestlers it is an
honor singers and even Terminators what
did they do the center terminated the
Sacramento right but not all celebrity
campaigns get that Hollywood ending like
Shirley Temple's attempted run for
Congress or Cynthia Nixon's bid for New
York Governor what's the ultimate like
the ultimate popularity contest right is
politics George Washington University
Professor Amani cheers says celebrity
candidates benefit from instant name
recognition which in political campaigns
is worth gold what do you think draws
celebrities into politics part of
celebrityism is enjoying the Limelight
enjoying being in front of people in the
spotlight Charisma comes with
celebrityism and they see Politics as a
way to continue to really have their
influence in the public Sphere for
voters we spoke to in Georgia and
Pennsylvania this cycle celebrity is is
a mixed bag I feel like if you are a
celebrity and you've already achieved
Fame and Fortune you're probably doing
this because you really care about your
country historically in the United
States we've had a really dangerous
relationship between the entertainment
industry and our politics and I think
right now we're seeing sort of Richard's
Pinnacle I see it as somebody who got
rich on TV
pushing fake cures and I can't take
anyone that would do that seriously as a
politician and when it comes to Walker
and Oz Democrats are hoping to make
celebrity a liability seems to me he's a
celebrity who wants to be a politician
and we've seen how that goes
we're at a point right now where it is
critical to have experience but is it
always important to have that in the
political Arena can you have experience
in other places and also be very
successful in politics so 2022 could
help determine whether more celebrities
run for office we're definitely not
going to go back to a traditional
establishment for CBS Saturday morning
Caitlin Huey Burns Philadelphia
I can't help but see that and think of
the Eddie Murphy movie The distinguished
gentleman well was it the name
recognition factor which is the idea of
celebrity that when people aren't
certain they go with that name
recognition well the notion is that if
you're a celebrity you have no level of
expertise you have no skill set you have
you know in in the general theme that
could apply to politics but that's not
necessarily true a mix as there is yes
it could be it could be it could be but
do you do diligence